Even though it's been a decade since the original
Zombieland, the wild ride across the country
is far from over.
For devoted fans who've been waiting for years
and for anyone just now discovering the first
film, let’s look at everything we know about
Zombieland 2: Double Tap.
This horror comedy sequel is currently scheduled
to come out on October 18, 2019.
That makes perfect sense, as that will be
just thirteen days before Halloween.
And there's another good reason for that particular
release date.
The first Zombieland crawled into theaters
on October 9, 2009, so the sequel is poised
to come out right around the one-decade anniversary.
That should be an ideal time to check out
where the four survivors landed after so many
years on the road as a highly dysfunctional
zombie-busting family.
Originally, October 11 was pegged as the release
date, but it was pushed back a week, where
it will open against Maleficent: Mistress
of Evil.
If Columbus and Tallahassee can defeat the
undead, we're pretty sure they'll be able
to hold their own against Angelina Jolie as
well.
Emma Stone, Abigail Breslin, Woody Harrelson,
and Jesse Eisenberg are all set to reprise
their roles, which means that our four heroes
stuck to their survival rules and made it
through the last decade in one piece.
And Bill Murray is even reportedly coming
back, which doesn't make a lick of sense,
as he, spoiler alert, met his unfortunate
and hilarious demise in the first movie.
"W-w-wait.
Who's Bill Murray?"
"Now I've never hit a kid before.
I mean, that's like asking who Gandhi is."
"Who's Gandhi?"
But that lapse in logic will be worth it,
as Murray is also bringing along his Ghostbusters
buddy, Dan Aykroyd.
And that's not the only new addition!
Avan Jogia will be playing Berkeley, a bad
boy musician, and Zoey Deutch and Rosario
Dawson show up as a couple of characters named
Madison and Nevada, respectively.
And finally, Luke Wilson and Thomas Middleditch
will also be joining in on the fun.
With all that talent assembled, we're expecting
a thoroughly entertaining sequel!
Plot details for Zombieland 2 have thus far
been kept under wraps, but we do know that
it takes place ten years after the original,
and that the zombies are way more dangerous
than before.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, the sequel
will send the main quartet "from the White
House to the American heartland as they face
off against new kinds of zombies that have
evolved since the first Zombieland, as well
as some new human survivors."
But perhaps toughest of all, they will also
have to "face the growing pains of their snarky,
makeshift family."
It's clear that everyone involved is excited
for part two.
But when it comes to quality, sequels have
often failed miserably in the past.
Fortunately for nervous Zombieland fans, Jesse
Eisenberg believes that his involvement in
the movie should come as a sign that something
good is brewing.
He told the Toronto Sun,
"We would never have made another one if we
didn't think it was going to be great.
They wrote a ton of scripts for this movie,
and we went through a lot of different ideas.
Finally, we have something I think people
are going to love."
And Emma Stone discussed the importance of
the cast's camaraderie during an appearance
on The Tonight Show.
"Jesse Eisenberg and Woody Harrelson."
“Oh yeah, and Abigail Breslin.
Yeah, it was so much fun.
We played a lot of game.
A lot of ping pong, a lot of pool…”
"A lot of board games."
The returning filmmaking talent also extends
behind the camera for Zombieland 2.
Ruben Fleischer is coming hot off the heels
of helming Venom as he settles into the director's
chair for Double Tap.
Plus, original writers Paul Wernick and Rhett
Reese are also coming back.
They too have been pretty busy in the last
few years, as they're the minds behind the
Deadpool franchise.
While nothing is confirmed, the gap in time
is expected to play a large part in Wernick
and Reese's story.
And Fleischer wants everyone to know that
the Zombieland creative team waited so long
for a sequel because they wanted to ensure
that they had a good idea.
As he told Latino Review Media,
"I'm proud to say I think our script is really
great, in that the movie will be as good as
the original if not better, and that's why
we're all back."
To tease fans, the Zombieland marketing team
took advantage of the "ten-year challenge"
meme that went viral recently to announce
the film's official title and show the cast
together again for the first time.
In the image shared on the official Zombieland
Twitter account in January 2019, Harrelson,
Eisenberg, Stone, and Breslin recreated their
poses from the first film's poster.
This time around, obviously, they're all ten
years older, even if a few of them don't look
it.
Unsurprisingly, Breslin looks the most different
of the bunch, as the 23-year-old actress was
only 13 when the original hit theaters.
But we imagine that most of the crew has their
same old attitudes, even without the ten-year
challenge reminding us how much things stay
the same.
Then on July 25, 2019, the first Double Tap
trailer arrived online.
The clip suggests that this unlikely unit
has settled into a comfortable life as a family.
They're even making strides toward normalcy,
as evidenced by a bit of a Christmas celebration.
Alas, things are thrown out of whack when
the zombie survivors must adapt to the newcomers
among the living.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.